I've got some new tour dates to announce
right now April 25th
at the celebrity theater in Phoenix
Arizona
we're adding a date onto that week March
23rd we've added in Houston Texas
uh that's a Thursday night at The Hobby
Lobby Center for the Performing Arts May
10th Newark New Jersey New Jersey Center
for the Performing Arts May 11th
Westbury New York at the New York CB
theater at Westbury
June 9th Austin we've added another
Austin show and June 30th and July 2nd
Las Vegas at the Encore Theater wow I
can't believe it man
oh I just can't even believe that uh
that we're getting to do all this
this is crazy thank you uh it's at
theovan.com
t-o-u-r you have to go through those
links to get accurately priced tickets
if you're elsewhere that's out of our
control
you know um there's already a lot of
monsters there on the internet with
these ticketing fees and those are out
of our control as well but uh I love you
guys and um and I hope to get to see you
if you can come out we now have be good
to yourself crewnecks available in light
blue maroon and cement that embankment
gang color you know it check these out
along with the new windbreaker at
theovinstore.com and thank you for your
support
today's guest is uh the founder of bar
stool and bar stool Sports
um he's uh
I mean he's a media
Legend uh he's kind of a revolutionary
in a way he's he's kind of a dang Paul
Revere
for a lot of people
um
he hasn't he has a unique ability he
makes you feel like anything is possible
and uh I'm grateful to have him here
today today's guest is Dave portnoway
[Music]
I don't know
and I will
follow
[Music]
we High I mean I hired a guy strictly
because
it was like yeah it was like in the like
he interviewed it was a Telly was
wallpaper I mean he was so boring but he
knew me he's like I have one thing that
may sway you like in my favor it's like
what he's like well I'm legally blind
I'm like well like can I make fun of you
for it like is it open game he's like
yeah so we hired him oh wow he's still
like sore he's still with us in a way
like to the point we thought he was
faking it because like he knew that
would get me so one day
we just and a bunch of people if I was
faking it so we called him up I'm like
I'm just gonna like toss my wallet to
him and see if he reacts smacked him
right in the face it's the only time I
felt bad so I he was literally literally
blind but he'd sit at his computer like
what you're saying with this huge
magnifying glass you tell him to do
something it took him four hours yeah
yeah yeah yeah it was kind of a gimmick
but not the most productive guy to ever
come down the street
yeah we we interviewed a blind woman one
time and uh it was pretty fascinating
she said she remembered like the E like
she almost feels like a computer
sometimes like how like she would
remember the way she would walk to
school and stuff like that so she lost
her sight
yeah she had some sight when she was
young and it wasn't a lot and then she
lost it completely yeah and so then she
had to like she said she started to feel
like a computer and the only animal she
didn't like she said was a snake she
said a snake doesn't give any feedback
she's like it just feels like
just like a piece of Satan I guess maybe
I was born to be one I don't like snakes
either yeah absolutely age-old question
like would you rather uh would you
rather like if you were blind would you
rather have been able to see or never
been able to see
I think I would like to if I'm gonna be
blind I'm going all in I'm saying never
see right because then you don't know
what you're missing yeah yeah and then
you can yell stuff you could use like I
don't want to say slurs but you could
probably say things that are
other people are gonna be like oh he
shouldn't say anything like oh he's
blind you know
what
um
Dave Portner thanks for coming in man
yep we don't know each other that great
you know definitely not yeah
definitely not I feel like maybe we're
I just met recently really for the first
time I think it was the uh no when's the
first time we met was it at the LSU uh
tailgate I think yeah and then we saw
each other a couple times after that
yeah
yeah man we're kind of like just sort of
getting to know each other
um and you are uh
you grew up in New York wrong see we
don't know each other that well Boston
oh yeah yeah and but does Boston always
have such a chip on their shoulder about
New York it's almost like it almost
seems like
um
there's more like it seemed like New
York but with more like kind of spousal
abuse kind of a little bit low-key you
know yeah I don't know I'd have to look
up the stats on that one uh
it there's definitely animosity I don't
know if it stems from like spousal abuse
but it's the uh you know New York so I
grew up in Boston and everybody in New
York is always like Boston is a little
town yeah it's not a city it's a town
you know you know you as a Boston guy
you kind of take offense to that then we
moved to New York and New York's it is
compared to Boston it's a small little
city but it's so close the sports
rivalry reminds me I was in Milwaukee
right and I did a pizza review which I
do and and I thought I was in Milwaukee
it's actually in a Racine oh yeah the
Racine Bells from um I was actually I
didn't realize it till after and I was
mad I didn't know that I would have
worked it in but Racine people are very
upset that I was calling it Milwaukee
like you're in Racine you're not
Milwaukee it's kind of that Vibe Boston
you know yeah like the underdog when you
were growing up what kind of like school
did you go to like what was it like when
you were growing up like traditionalized
middle class went to all public like
swamps got uh just I grew the town I
grew up was called Swan Scott so I just
went to the normal high school normal
normal Middle School Normal everything
like my friends that I grew up with are
still like really my best friends oh
yeah yeah and what was it like at your
house like was your dad pretty cool or
what was he like
no he's definitely I want to that cool
is not the word I I would ever describe
my dad as he's like
my parents are like the seinfelds that's
a better way to like Morty you know
Morty and he takes by the way great
offense to that oh he loved it no no he
if you're like you're like Morty
Seinfeld when Morty Seinfeld does
something weird and so he's like no I'm
not what are you talking about but he is
exactly like them they're kind of maybe
the traditional like over protective
like Jewish like family parents kind of
that's what they are is it fun so you've
been doing your whole life I mean yeah
yeah okay is it fun being Jewish like
what is it like like no I won't say it's
fun it's nothing like I wasn't overly
religious right so but it I no I
wouldn't say it's fun you're gonna
battle you know I I I always like
Jews you know there's more everyone
celebrates Christmas like far fewer to
uh Hanukkah so like in the early days
the bar stool we had this guy Kevin
Clancy gets the big ass tree you know
it's like well if we're gonna do a big
ass tree I'm gonna get a big ass manure
we have the biggest manure like ever
made it had to be like put together in
the office just so we weren't getting
like short shifted on it but uh yeah no
I don't I don't really give a [__]
um I'm not overly religious I mean you
know I'll stick up for Jews if we're
getting like if Kanye is like you know
Hitler wasn't that bad of a dude I'll be
able to hold on there like he kind of
was like I don't I like well he did rail
he did the the highway system I'm like
yeah but you know he used it wrong yeah
he killed a lot of us too so I don't
know that one plus one equals two
whatever so but I'm not you know I'm not
overly but like [__] like that I will
get involved like yeah when people are
defending him it's like the guys out
here like basically pro-hitler how can I
even defend him so that [__] I'll speak
up on but
I'm not you know I'm not overly like a
lot of the holidays I don't follow and
stuff like that yeah yeah that's always
wonder like probably half of my closest
friends are Jewish especially once you
get to like LA or New York you meet a
lot more Jewish people they didn't have
like a lot of Jewish people when I was
growing up so we're running the media
yeah that's what they say I mean
yeah I don't I mean there's so many
Jewish people that work in the media I
don't know I have no idea you know it's
like I don't know who's
I don't know who's if somebody's really
running something I don't know no well I
mean it's like anything you can look I
run barcel sports that's the media
company I work my ass for it I mean
whatever it listen there's bad people or
scumbags in every race religion Creed
whatever oh yeah uh Jews get a bad rap
but a lot of people get bad raps so what
yeah I was just wondering what is it
like like does it feel I wonder if it
feels different being Jewish does it
feel like
like do I wake up I'm like damn I'm Jew
or like yeah I get I I don't know I
guess I don't even know what I'm asking
I guess I just I guess someone would
wonder what it feels like yeah I guess
like the thing about it though which
I've always said so because Jewish
people are very determined Jewish people
like to create value and yeah well I
think it's kind of like a family thing
like they're very very education very
hard working
um and put uh a premium on that and then
it shows but the thing about being
Jewish which I've always pointed out
that we're getting deep but it's like
people say you'll hear this a lot like
what are you and someone will be like
I'm Italian I'm [__] you know Russian
I'm Jewish
but Jewish like if I want to change
being Jewish tomorrow I could it's not
like a blood thing Jewish is a religion
that you choose if someone wants to be
Catholic they can choose it in a second
you can't change being like Italian if
you're that's what you are like if
you're born from there so Jewish it's
kind of one of those things over time I
think it's probably out of prejudice
people make it sound like it's your
blood it's [__] not your blood it's
like it's your religion that somewhere
along the way somebody chose to believe
but you can change it like I'm Russian
that's my my family is from who you are
I could see that a little bit now yeah
and and we don't in my family to be
honest we don't talk like I don't even
know that much about the history I'm
sure bad [__] happened like most people
don't leave their country just because
Daniel you're Russian yeah yeah Russian
dang yep
wow man
that's great man I don't know I knew
this one Russian girl and she was so
sexy man and God she invited me over one
time and like she was sick or something
I brought her some soup and she like was
so aggressively trying to [__] that I
guess she didn't feel well yeah and so
that I was like oh what do you do here
you know like see I'm such a
hypochondriac I would I'd be like not
like you got to get healthy well that's
kind of how I was I was so scared
there's like you know I kept trying to
lead her back to the soup and she kept
coming for me and uh and I got so scared
because she was sick but she was so like
aggressive and determined and it's wild
yeah it was interesting man and she
actually went to J she went to jail I
remember she hit me up like years later
to come testify for her in some thing
and I couldn't make it all right I just
wanted to sleep in honestly yeah that's
tough like if you're being asked to
testify and you're like sorry oh you
must not have really been that close
with her yep the you know Skip the trial
or whatever she was going down for she's
like I need somebody to show up yeah I
guess I guess my question is that like I
does it feel do you feel a lot of
pressure being Jewish to be successful
no
no that's interesting no I don't feel
pressured to be successful at all but no
nothing to do with if anything like I
feel like there no there's a lot of
successful Jews yeah my parents weren't
like hey you're Jewish you better be
successful no oh maybe that's what it is
maybe I've had a lot of friends of my a
lot of my Jewish friends are successful
you know and so it's like
um yeah I guess I wonder do I feel like
that there's a pressure and then all my
Jewish friends are always saying that
their moms are always driving them nuts
and so I guess I started doing that I
started to put those things together I
love my mother she's coming to the Super
Bowl with me just to like probably get
away from my dad for a couple days but
like my mother's the type of woman and
again this is a typical like I go home
I'll go back to wherever I'm going and
you know I open my like suitcase and
they'll be like geez it's hidden in
there and like all sorts of gadgets like
she's just a overprotective like she
doesn't anything I say I don't want that
I don't do this she'll do it like she's
always you know if I could walk around
giant bubble like that's what they do
like my grandmother remember one time I
was looking at colleges and there was a
plane crash we were driving yeah and she
called work she's like the plane crash
you're all right like we we weren't we
weren't flying she's like well the plane
could have landed on you like that's the
type of like thing you know just a
little bit overly protective
okay interesting but no pressure no
pressure in that I mean uh I originally
want to be like a gym teacher like that
was what I graduated actually college
with and they would have been fine with
it they've been supportive no pressure
at all they're just I think the Jewish
thing for my it's just most uh just
super intense on like education like do
good in school like if you if you're
[__] off on school my parents would
be like what are you doing right and I
did [__] off a little bit at school but
that they'd be in your grill about that
yeah that's it were you
um yeah cause I'm just curious you know
I'm just curious and so do you like did
in high school were you like kind of
like a funny guy where you like kind of
like the guy who was like the student
council leader like what kind of like
what was some of your vibe in high
school so yeah I I I I played Sports
hung out with like your Riz actually
which I learned what it means from you
and your Tick Tock I didn't know yeah I
didn't know that either until yeah with
those [__] kids up on game [__] them
yeah right so I mean are good kids
so this should give you a insight into
the like
I I and this is again my parents being
like you got to get your resume right
for like going to college so I was the
vice president of my class and that was
like calculated because I didn't want to
do the work so I was like I'm not gonna
run for president because then you got
to do [__] vice president kind of skate
but put it on the resume so that's what
I did and then I played uh Sports so I
was just again I'd say I ran in like the
uh the popular crowd but I was friends
with everybody yeah a little bit funny
yeah you know I couldn't get buying
looks so if you don't go looks you go
funny yeah oh yeah trust me dude I feel
you I'm like an eight I've always been
kind of like an eight
and you gotta [__] you gotta an eight
you gotta come up with some jokes yeah
like on looks I think I'm out of a ten
yeah that's a [__] super high score
I don't think you think it's that high
yeah
eight eight so who's a ten
like what's Matthew McConaughey
I think he was a 10. I think he's coming
down a touch all right let's let's go
somebody who's I mean look the kid you
work with Josh Richards okay yeah I mean
the guy is B yeah I mean he's an
attractive woman I mean he's yeah no
he's a good looking guy he's like he's
the [__] um I'm sorry it actually
turned 21. yesterday but he's like the
uh Calvin Klein's yeah he's doing Calvin
Klein's like oh my God yes all right God
I'd put tits on him found him I know
that I know he's a good looking kid he
always is when I walked in with that
original Tick Tock crew he's he's
definitely good looking guy smart kid
too he looks like a mannequin there's a
good picture of you guys together right
there impersonating each other yeah that
was like the first time we met so we
that's when we watched it you guys meet
at dude so do you know you probably do
know this guy know this guy because he
knows [__] everybody do you know
Michael Gruen Michael ruin knows Bruin
no that's surprising because I feel like
this dude knows everybody
um so there he is
um no but he looks like kind of like a
uh so basically I was on Twitter one day
and uh
Dixie Demello yeah she broke up with her
boyfriend at the time you may not these
were these are huge yeah I know she is
yeah so she was like the original kind
of it girl on Tick Tock oh yeah yeah
yeah and it broke into Twitter okay and
they broke up and I and everyone was
talking about Twitter and I was like who
the [__] are these people Gruen who is
Josh uh Richard's manager reached out
he's like hey he'll explain it to you
want to do a Instagram live with him so
like sure we did it and I was surprised
we kind of like had some chemistry like
who is this kid Snapchat reached out
after we did that like would you guys do
a show on Snapchat I had no interest
because I wasn't
like Snapchat just wasn't where I want
to be Tick Tock I knew it was something
it's like I'm sure you view the world at
times like all right I gotta get my name
like who are these kids on Tick Tock
because parcel have been around for a
while but nobody knew us on Tick Tock
was a younger demo so to me partnering
with him who was big on Tick Tock he's
like all right that's gonna get me
Barstool maybe this new audience and
that's where it came from he wanted to
get maybe a little more credible with
like an older crowd who had been around
I want to get the tick tock crowd to
know who we were and that's where it
came from it's great yeah I came on that
show so Michael Gruen is his manager he
was he was okay and and he he like just
connected people he uh yeah you know I
still hear blue ones yeah he he when I
first met him no joke to Gruen the first
thing I said to him was he was the most
obnoxious human I ever met is he really
he grew on me but he can come across as
sandpaper when you meet him but I do
like him now
he's grueling on people huh yeah well
played oh wow and yeah uh I would like
to maybe meet that guy but then I yeah
it's interesting if people kind of get
onto your nerves you know I had this
dude that used to kind of would always
kind of bite the air a little bit he had
a little bit of a
just a little hitch in him you know like
uh like Val Kilmer like Iceman
like that like he was eating a berry off
a tree or something you know and he
would do that just every now and then
and like you can deal with it for a
while but after about that 50th Berry
you gotta [__] shut him down or you
got to leave the room do you know the
part I'm talking about with Iceman and
Top Gun he just he's like uh that's
right ice man I am dangerous I just
based there does the book oh he does
that yeah
um so in high school so yeah I could I
could see that man I could see you did
you feel like you had kind of like that
so obviously you knew that you could
kind of relate to everybody then a
little bit yeah that was because
sometimes as you get a little you start
to learn just some of your skills you're
like oh I kind of can fit in wherever
yeah I was pretty good at that did you
have a lady in high school or no no no
no no no uh
no I wasn't good looking I didn't really
do great with the girls at all in high
school what about like for dance is
there anything did you ask a lady out
ever like do you remember like the first
date you ever went on or anything like
that
first date no I I don't I mean I
remember obviously going to like proms I
know who I went to proms with and [__]
like that but no I didn't really uh I I
had very little if any
successful yeah yeah
blue eye you're handsome guy yeah I
don't know no I well first of all I went
through it like there's a whole fat day
of stage not that wasn't high school but
I mean I and I'm getting back to it
because I'm getting old but yeah no it's
the truth I tell you you always hear
like you know good looking people be
like no I didn't do anything like I was
ugly in like high school no I I was like
I'm not like those I don't believe the
good people like Jon Hamm like oh I I
have it rough my dick's too big you know
like no that I I really didn't do well
in high school yeah yeah I have to wear
like an 80 gauge Underpants just to hold
them up yeah like that kind of [__] yeah
I hate that
um yeah do you remember like even just
like what about your first kiss in high
school what had to have happened huh
yeah I I'm trying to think who did I
kiss first uh I don't even know if I
remember it couldn't have been anything
you mean dude you were a document tour
of no I don't know it couldn't have been
that memorable
I I'm honestly trying to think I don't I
don't know if that's like sad or what
but I I honestly can't remember wow yeah
some people I remember locked us in this
room and they had this girl and she had
like a chipped tooth she had that kind
of that Lloyd Christmas on her you know
or at least the Christmas tell me your
first guess it was like were you playing
like spin the ball you locked in a room
or you just locked in the room just
angry like kind of pervy older kids like
you better get in there and [__] kiss
you know what I'm saying or we're gonna
jerk off out here and we're like Jesus
Christ all right I took a turn and so uh
but she had that Lloyd Christmas or at
least she had the Lord she had like that
Lloyd Christmas Eve it was like a less
of a chip
but she had that thing and I remember
God she was also she was like the first
girl I ever remember really like seeing
with my eyes and she was
her name was Chrissy and she was
beautiful I thought and just bite the
teeth yeah so we had to sit next to each
other and just kiss
um what about the first time you had sex
you remember it that I do yeah yeah now
we're talking that that's a little
different than like a kiss yeah yeah it
wasn't great it's still probably not
[__] great you know oh yeah dude yeah
yeah when did it happen College freshman
his girlfriend yeah okay was it at a
party or was it like kind of a uh no it
was actually at so it it was at my house
it was actually summer going into
college okay yeah oh yeah dude I I love
like I love thinking about like those
kind of like just like times when we
were young and stuff like yeah there was
nothing like that time getting ready for
college and then I almost feel like that
was the time you feel like you had to
like
you had to get sex active you were going
into college college and you don't
really know what you expect yeah no I
mean it was like a romantic thing did
y'all go to like yeah it knows romantic
it was definitely romantic she was my
girlfriend so it was a romantic that's
cool
that's cool man you know I'm learning
Spanish right now
I I know some but I'm learning Moss
and one way to
integrate a new language into your life
is with Babel Babel is the language
learning app that sold more than 10
million subscriptions
you never know where life can take you
and to be prepared or to prepare
for those upcoming unique opportunities
Babel can help
thanks to Babel's addictively fun and
bite-sized language lessons you can feel
confident no matter where
this year takes you there are so many
ways to learn with Babel in addition to
lessons you can access podcasts Games
videos stories and even live classes
plus it comes with a 20-day money-back
guarantee right now get up to 55 off
your subscription when you go to
babbel.com
Theo that's
b-a-b-b-e-l.com slash Theo for up to 55
percent
off your subscription Babble language
for life do you know the number one
cause of abandoned shopping carts online
shipping costs
that's right
have you ever left a cart full of items
in an online store because the shipping
was too expensive
so have I
well in a landscape where free and fast
shipping is the norm it can be hard for
smaller e-commerce businesses to compete
keep yourself competitive with ship
station
when you use ship station you can lower
shipping costs make returns easy and
keep your customers happy
ship station
effortlessly integrates everywhere you
sell online Amazon
Etsy eBay Shopify and more
get up to 88 off USPS and UPS rates and
if that's not enough use my promo code
to try ship station free for two months
if you're shipping if you're vending if
you are out
selling things to people and you got to
get them to them
get it done with ship station
over 130 000 companies have grown their
e-commerce business with ship station
use promo code Theo
today at shipstation.com
to sign up for your free 60-day trial
that's
shipstation.com promo code
t-h-e-o ship station
thank you for sponsoring the show
yeah dude I ended up the first time I
ever hooked up was actually behind a
bowling alley in our town yeah my mine
was sounds more romantic than that yeah
potentially yeah oh it was mine people
were throwing rocks at us dude and it
was like yeah it was like trying to [__]
on the Gaza Strip or something I mean
people were [__] there was like it
was hard so were people like watching if
they're throwing rocks at you I wouldn't
say they were watching but they were
checking in a lot yeah yeah you know no
mine was not like that yeah mine was
probably pretty traditional yeah
yeah dude I remember one time I got so
nervous some girl and I tried to have
sex and I just couldn't I just like
I remember just
I ended up ejaculating and
and then she left and she was
embarrassed she climbed out of my window
in my room too I remember she was afraid
to even like leave through the living
room I think oh it was [__]
embarrassing because why
I think why did you go through the
window I think she was maybe just
I don't know I think it was just the
whole thing was a lot for everybody I
think everybody was kind of didn't know
their way around the world right after
it it was just it was like we planned on
it we were excited and I just and so
then you're sitting there with all and
you literally have your shame is right
there like in a liquid yeah you know
it's like hey here's it you're talking
if you if you bust you're not fast oh
yeah I mean I ejaculated immediately
well guys yeah and it was like that
scientifically means you're like uh good
right the faster the better that's
that's how we're programmed that's true
if we were like in the jungle days or
something we would be do it move on on
to the next one that's how it goes
that's efficient it's gonna be Elon bust
yeah I'd be [__] it's true yeah
um but yeah I think at that point
everybody was so just confused people
weren't even using the doorway anymore
like it was just that kind of thing you
know
um actually if you pull up look up uh
bowling alley bowling in
Saint Tammany Parish
this place looks like it's the [__]
bowling capital of the world a lot of
bowling alleys in a very short area yeah
if you look on that one Tiffany Lane's a
3.4 Stars
just click on that one if you oh man
there's a review somewhere and somebody
wrote so you can go to the first review
on there oh it's closed down yeah
somebody sent me the other day it says
like sometimes there's like
oh there you go
oh this was like the top question on
there I'm here because of uh theobon
became a man behind this building
it was just a crazy thing one of my
friends said hey I'm looking for a place
to bowl locally and this came up and the
top thing says that the Obama came so
it's like a known fact this is where he
lost your virginity picking up splits
homie in there cuz love it
um interesting man yeah I was just kind
of wondering like what maybe you were
like when you were younger you know yeah
it's like I said traditional I don't
very very uh
forgettable probably a lot of a lot of
people like me normal normal growing
played Sports ran with like the the
popular crowd in school but just one of
the guys yeah you love sports now it
seems to be like something you really
love do you really really love it do you
love just the gambling do you love
sports yeah so I always love sports I
love gambling right obviously it's what
we do now so that worked out like before
I started Barcelona I was trying I want
to get into that industry right yeah I
flew out to Vegas tried to do all the
stuff so it's worked out perfectly for
me I'm probably like one of the few guys
who's made money through gambling most
people get wiped out
um so yeah no I'm a big sports fan and
obviously it's been a core part of what
we do so it makes me like I'm not
uh maybe I'm not getting arrested and
going to jail if we're not doing
Barstool I'm not like that crazy if I
was just sitting around as a normal fan
okay um but I love sports yeah Boston
Sports guy through and through yeah
um do you think that they should have
legal gambling like everywhere because I
know you guys work with your gambling
site is I know Sports Social Sports
Books Okay personal sports book yeah and
they even have bars like I was in Baton
Rouge and they have like a barcel
Sportsbook bar in the casino yeah yeah
because so we were bought by a company
called pen and they have uh L'Auberge we
also have like Standalone so we're
actually getting one here in Nashville
like yeah or they'll be a barcel sports
bar it's where like the old uh Joe's
Crab Shack used to be so it's a good
spot
um
so I think it will eventually go Most
states but it it so gambling became
legal to bet on Sports outside of Vegas
maybe two years ago two and a half
something like that they repealed some
federal law and now it's up to the
states so they just decide state by
state so I think we're live in like
maybe 11 or 12 States and do you Lobby
for that somehow or you just that's just
let the world do that our parent company
lobbies for it and all the different
companies that are involved in that
Lobby for it and there's people Lobby
against it so I have nothing to do with
it but yeah there's a lot of politicking
going around with that do you get more
joy out of making like a big wager on
one thing or hitting like a crazy parlay
you know I don't do as much as parlays
so like bet on one thing winning it I
mean I I bet my whole life so it's just
but yeah not it's I love it I love
gambling yeah you like to gamble like do
you feel like that that's just like a
thing you'd like to do just with sports
or even like kind of with everything
like you kind of like to go kind of like
the alternate route a little bit yeah
yeah it's I definitely even Barstool
like I think being an entrepreneur kind
of is like gambling different different
respect but I saw barcel with nothing
really and everything we made we put
back into it for the most part work but
you know we did concert I thought we
were going out of business at one point
because I put all our money into like a
concert tour and it kind of who was it
like Third Eye Blind or something no
believe it or not so we did this thing
it we had never left downtown Boston
ever and and I was like all right we
gotta see if we're big outside of Boston
and we had liquor sponsors at the time
and they were like well you know we
can't sponsor you if you're going to
colleges and we're like well what if we
make it a Music Tour could you they said
yeah so we had this kid Sam Adams um it
kind of blew up and he's got some big
songs we did it we did six six stops and
it went really well
um bigger than we ever thought and I I
looked at it so we originally thought
we're going like frats and you we go to
UMass and this the actual School calls
like hey we were again all these
requests for tickets what is this so we
went from the Frat to the actual like
Mullen Center which is the gymnasium
sold out in a second my brain's going
the business side's like hey if I can
recreate this with like big talent I may
be on to something so we had a Music
Tour it was headlined uh by Mike Posner
do you remember like cooler than me at
the time I saw Mike two weeks ago yeah
so that song just came out he was the
headliner it was uh him Wally I had Mac
Miller for 1500 bucks that's how much we
were paying him to play so he was the
third guy coming up on it uh and nobody
[__] bought well people bought
tickets same amount as the first time we
went around it turned out our crowd they
weren't coming necessarily for who we're
booking they're coming because Barstool
was on it oh wow we got [__] wiped
out I actually hated posing he didn't
promote the [__] he didn't promote it at
all not his fault his agent's fault
um so that was a disaster and then we
moved from that because it was kind of
like all right if people are coming for
bar stool not the talent does it really
matter and we went into EDM so you lost
you lost your butt on that smoked
because you had to pay the act so much
pay the accent I rented the buildings so
we were going I was paying like Yeah The
Vig on that building like 100 Grand or
something a night and we weren't doing
it I thought I was gonna have to pay the
full thing we had to cancel a lot of the
shows so
um that was a disaster and then we we
came up with something called the
Blackout Tour which essentially was a DJ
playing EDM music this is at the infancy
of EDM and it exploded like to the point
we had I bought all our own production
you could go to an EDM show it looked
like ours we had a full crew doing it I
thought and were you into it were you
like doing the pills and everybody like
partying no we had I I would we we did
three shows a week throughout the
country like we had a whole crew driving
around setting up the lights renting
venues
um I thought I thought I was gonna
become so rich that I'd be like Bezos
and retire we were clearing like 250
Grand to show it was nuts and we weren't
paying for talent so we're charging 50
bucks a ticket selling out literally and
it was just like an EDM party show yes
so This Crew so you guys were just in
Boston and this crew is now traveling
doing shows for you correct like have
you ever heard there's a festival like
bamboozle it's a big Festival in New
Jersey so the Bonnaroo bamboozle is like
one of those type things yeah and we
were on a call with Live Nation uh I'll
never forget this call like we want you
to close the last music they had was Bon
Jovi they're like we want you to come on
after Bon Jovi and close it like we'll
pay you 250 Grand just to show up and
before we could say anything like we
know it's not a lot of money it's cheap
um but you'll introduce your music to so
many new people and I was like wait wait
we don't have music what are you talking
about there's no one like what do you
mean you have no music the only thing
they saw was our ticket sales in their
system whenever we put tickets they were
gone in 10 seconds wow so we like did
that turned into a foam thing but but
that was because of the bar stool name
again so you're still like we're just
selling EDM yeah dude because where I'm
from if somebody showed up with damn two
laser lights and a [__] flood beam
dude people would pay 50 dollars nuts
for it and it was [__] like we had
outside of it like we had Avicii like
playing our thing for like no money it
was before the DJ thing took off okay so
so you did actually have talent coming
to the yeah we rotate but we won't pay a
lot like we did we paid maybe two grand
for Avicii but it just they it was
before the DJ boom right then the DJ
boom started happening and a couple
things happened we had our name and
we're always sort of controversial but
if somebody OD'd at EDM Vegas yeah we
would be mentioned it'd be like barcel
uh blackout or part of this and people
would be calling me Insurance went
through the roof
um and news crews were following like
our production around just looking for
controversy so the whole thing as quick
as it came it disappeared so because of
insurance really Insurance EDM it went
from there'd be one EDM show at a
college a month so there were three a
week and we were playing Avicii's music
and Avicii was going to be there
tomorrow so all host of factors and I
was investing this is the gambling part
every cent I made I'm like let's get the
next biggest laser let's get this let's
get that so we put it all back in at the
end of the day we're probably not even
like we we didn't make money we didn't
lose money
when it comes to business sense do you
has that been a was that a tough thing
to realize like even just as my own
business and and world has grown like
it's tough sometimes to realize
especially if you don't come from a lot
to reinvest and stuff is that always I
mean obviously in that instance it kind
of evened out yep but do you has that
like been a tough thing for you to
realize or is that like what no the for
me that's been like uh
that's just something I think that
that's in my like blood that goes back
to the gambling uh like I've made money
I don't think I need money like I didn't
have any for a long time not that I was
like living like I could eat but uh no I
just have a risk taker personality so I
I never I I'm always like pushing things
into the middle now I'm at a different
stage in my life right so would I risk
it all now I've been doing this for 20
years be like if I thought there was a
huge opportunity I'm gonna put
everything back probably not but at that
point we were still pushing yeah that's
so cool man because you kind of became
like this guy who's like I'll [__]
put it on the table right now you know
even throughout like the pandemic and
stuff like
um the way you were like kind of uh you
know you were championing like keeping
small businesses open and what the what
are we doing here
um not afraid to interview Trump or to
talk about you know conservative like
views or even look at them you know when
a lot of the world was like mainstream
media was like kind of shunning them do
you get is that kind of a little bit of
the high because I'm just wondering like
because gambling is kind of a high but
there's a little bit of high and [__]
gambling with yourself as well yeah
that's always you know we never look for
fights with that stuff I'm pretty I'm
pretty much a free speaker I have had to
tone it down uh which is I got a lot of
haters out there and I always say
probably the number one benefit they
have that they don't realize is that
Penn the gambling company bought us
because we are regulated so it's it's
for the first time since I've been doing
Barstool people can sort of get at me
through a side door like I don't care
what you [__] say about me I really
don't and I have thick skin and if
you're gonna come at me I'll come at you
like I've done things that not like I've
staked out [__] a New York Times
Reporter like who was I know digging
through my [__] past in life and
trying to like really write a nasty hit
piece about me it's like if you want to
[__] talk to me let's [__] talk
and I wait I did like a uh 48 Hours like
I literally parked my car with my camera
guy outside the house for like six hours
and just waited for them to come out ran
out and like confronted them
um I like doing that I like I just I
it's like I'm a confrontational person
by Nature so that that part of me has
always been there I have had to tone it
down a little bit because I don't
barcel's so much bigger than just me now
and right what I do does affect other
people
um and I see it like I go on Fox News
I'll go and talk to Carlson and he knows
I'm not overly like political but every
time I go on there that affects how
people view the whole company and some
people may have different views whatever
so that that I do sort of pay attention
to it still doesn't affect necessarily
what I do like people are mad within our
company that I interviewed Trump right
but you know you're gonna make the
decisions you think are right at the
time yeah dude there was a fun that
interview was so funny man when he was
like you're like you ever just rattle
off a tweet and then just kind of hit
he's like I still think I'm the only guy
who's ever gotten him to say like yeah I
regret something he's like yeah I do
regret it I don't know that he's ever
been like I regret something in his life
except for that yeah it was so good but
he's like yeah you know you just write
it and go to sleep yeah you wake up
you're like what the [__] did I write
he's like yeah I've done that I've done
that he was listen people have such
strong opinions about him uh I think
right off the bat he kind of realized I
wasn't like out to be like gotcha right
uh so he he was he was good with me he
was down to earth he was he was not like
his guard wasn't up it was surreal
experience oh look yeah I can only
imagine I remember watching he's
watching that interview and watching you
sit there I'm like god dude that'd be so
like first of all Dave's doing this you
know like he's actually going and like
you know whereas everybody else was just
like making fun of trump or not even
giving him a chance I mean mainstream
media did not I mean he didn't help
himself certain points but they didn't
help him out of the gate or give them a
chance but yeah right there it's sort of
there's definitely a similarity with him
and how I it's like if you come at him
he'll be a dick 10 times harder back to
you
um when you're president that can cause
like issues like I have so many things
that people still bring up with me and
they'll bring up quotes or whatever and
somebody who came after me and I'm being
like so sarcastic and an [__] back to
them and then they take what it is so I
see it but you're right he's uh you know
he's the pre he was the president yeah
so
like I'm not the president so I can do a
lot of things I'm not trying to be
presidential and I think some people
like well you should be and he he's a
totally different cat
oh I remember when he was running I
thought right at the beginning I was
like he's gonna win I was like he just
sounds like he just it seems like it's
not a part of a bigger plan you know but
then I wonder once he got an office did
is it just too convoluted in there or
was he just kind of overshooting his own
Mark or you know that's what I kind of
Wonder because in the beginning he was
kind of like even though he wasn't
really like this came from nothing kind
of guy he was kind of talking to a lot
of people that I think felt
underrepresented or you know or people
who want some tradition in the country
you know and it's like he was dismissed
by so many people and I think
that almost made him more popular with
the people he was resonating like any
way you look at it he won the election
so there's a large large large portion
of the country he was speaking to and
people are so dismissive if you weren't
on his side if if you like Trump you're
like a racist [__] idiot yeah that's
like so so you're saying like more than
half the country are those people now
I'm sure there's definitely a subsection
within his demo that do fit that
description but certainly not everybody
and you just paint everybody with one
brush and actually made them more
popular doing that oh for sure you know
I've said before I he's intentionally
divisive which you know I I want people
to get along so that that that's where I
kind of lose it like and it's not just
him it's both sides it's like you need
somebody who at least honestly wants to
bring people together and that I don't
know who that's going to [__] be
that's a good point huh yeah you do and
it's it's not Biden because he he's so
dismissive of the people who do like
Trump it's like they're just
everything's now it is and so that sucks
it is it takes away almost half the
dating pool I think for a lot of people
too I think about that sometimes because
you know it like it used to be you know
every it used to be it didn't matter so
much
um if someone like you'd have husbands
and wives at a different politics just
kind of yeah no it's toxic now it's
gotten weird
um would you ever run for like a
governor or something [__] no
I ran for mayor of Boston oh you did
yeah I didn't know that I tried to they
they [__] blackballed me so
this was Boston [__] they did they did
this is I'm telling I was doing that
black people get blackballed all kind of
stuff I was doing the Blackout Tour that
I told you about okay so we rented these
venues we House of Blues is a venue of
Boston like 3 000 people we sold it out
I think seven straight days in like 30
seconds we were doing it so there's a
ton of schools in Boston so like Hey
Monday it's bu barcel blackout Tuesday
BC Wednesday Northeastern so all the
kids at each school would buy it sold
out instantly the the police were so
[__] like bad they they were breath
have you ever heard of kids getting
breathalyzed in line going down the line
if we sold 3 000 tickets like 20 kids
gone into the show everyone else too
drunk this that I was like this is
[__] [__] so
um I'm like I'm gonna run for mayor so
they can't do this [__] to me anymore uh
and you had to basically get what was it
like 12 000 signatures to get on the
ballot now there's two parts of the
signatures you had to be able to read
the signature and the person had to be a
registered voter I hired a full-blown
agency that you have professional people
get it uh get the signatures we had like
20 000 they just ruled ten thousand of
them didn't count there's no way to
appeal there's no nothing so I didn't
make it onto the uh ballot but yeah I I
was like trying to do it that's wild but
other than that no who needs that I
don't who would ever
I've used this quote like the movie
Gladiator when Maximus
um it's the the the king or uh wants
Maximus to be the the lead of Rome he's
like no thanks though who wants that
headache and he's like that's exactly
why you have to do it who would who in
their right mind would want to be in
politics well like you the person who
want politics should be somebody who's
not doing it for ego who truly cares
about like the well-being of the people
not doing it to money get rich none of
the politicians do that now because why
would you like I never understood that
with Trump like you're this Rich dude
nobody really hates you like people
actually kind of Love You on The
Apprentice yeah like you know you have
no ill will he's gonna go down is one of
the most hated dudes who ever lived like
why it just I guess ego like yeah maybe
that's ego I mean I could see it if
somebody could say you get to be
president yeah everybody wants to be you
know or a little better you I mean maybe
for like an a you know a couple hours I
don't know if I would do a full term you
know like I think I'd want to be in the
office and like walk down and see like
that well that's ego yeah it's ego yeah
that's it which is cool but the amount
of hate and the amount like I I get so
much hate and it's all political like
people who don't like me always if you
don't like Dave Florida I can go to your
Twitter and within three you have
something political on your timeline
yeah and it's like who needs that no I
don't know how isolated like these guys
are like when I went and visited Trump
you know everyone's sold pro-trump it's
like he maybe he doesn't even hate
doesn't get to him on a level I don't
know but no I won't never run yeah but
do you think 10 years from now you're
like I am and I'm [__] around you no
[__] way wow no I think we would I I
would I mean I guess part of me would
like to see you have but then also I I
sometimes feel like politics is just
this like
it's this this shell company for actual
real leaders which is a lot of it is in
the tech world this these days yeah and
even if you look at like you mentioned
the Barstool fund which we gave away 50
million basically wow like the
government couldn't do that they they
move so [__] slow if you actually
want to get stuff done it's way easier
to do it the way I did it which is we
just set it up 24 hours later the
money's going in and the second the
money comes in the money's going out
they did the government basically did
nothing for like small business they're
still talking about now and so much
fraud with the PPP and [__] like that so
I don't know if it's hard yeah and if
you really want to get stuff done you
can get stuff done not within you know
the government well it's almost becoming
more like that I think in in the in
America these days it's like
there's all the like you know there's a
few kind there's less companies there's
less mom and pop places there's just a
few larger companies oh totally man it's
ridiculous I wish we had never done so
much globalization I don't know a lot
about that kind of stuff but it's like
you know the guy the kid down the street
it used to be their dad worked at the
factory in the town and they were proud
of like if their dad's factory made
tables they were proud of the table they
had in their house my dad made this you
know and there was like a sense of like
you were doing something now your table
comes from China you have no idea the
Dad's doing pills the kid is in the
other room you know cooking pills and
then there's a guy in China making a
table his gets shipped off he never sees
they're just like I mean it's kind of a
very small example but no that was a
small business we look for like
generational and that was so sad about
it like nobody was helping these people
it it really was crazy it's like hey you
can't have customers right but we're not
going to give you the money so like what
do they think is going to happen yeah
it's like that that to me was always the
wildest part yeah
and again I mean you've built up your
career over the time the barcel was the
same I always looked at like I worked my
dick off to get where I was and then if
something that's so far out of control
and it just vanishes like that and
nobody's there to like that is what the
government in my that's what it's
[__] for like that is what we're
paying taxes and all this [__] nobody
was nowhere to be found like if you want
to keep [__] closed fine but you better
figure out how to take care of the
people who need things to be open or let
people make their own decisions one
another
yeah I agree I mean I go to a lot of
like recovery meetings and stuff and
they closed all those recovery rooms
right right that's crazy bro I had no
joke I had five maybe six friends that
overdosed and died during the pandemic
right died like and it was and people
were like well it's not because but they
need those rooms like they just [__]
shut it down like what do you think
people I'd rather have covered than yeah
you know and to be honest that was
always my point it's like you let let
people decide right like if you were
you know like my parents or whoever like
scared of covert you do have the option
to stay inside like nobody's coming into
your house you can you can live your
life pretty safely I get it I mean it
was crazy [__] it's like a horror
movie who knows yeah [__] like people
right there like at their funerals over
Zoom like you know what I'm saying like
what the [__] that's crazy crazy time
yeah crazy time and then I talked to my
friends in Mexican like yeah nobody's
doing [__] down here dude we're [__]
partying we're shooting each other we're
[__] having a blast you know we're
drinking they're shooting each other I
mean not you know not shoot you know or
probably grazing each other but there's
a lot of violence down there
um today's episode is brought to you by
betterhelp we are grateful for their
support
and I'm grateful for what they do
you know we all have times in our life
where we need to get some help
you know I saw someone at um at a show
this weekend in Indianapolis and they
came up and said hey man uh I want to
thank you for just talking about getting
therapy and and getting help because I
needed it
and uh and I need it heck I get it every
week better help
when you're at your best you can do
great things but sometimes life gets you
bogged down
and you may feel overwhelmed
or like you aren't showing up in the way
that you want to maybe you're not
tickling your kids or you're not
um
you know getting yourself an ice cream
or taking yourself on a run or doing
something you love or reading reading a
book
well working with a therapist can help
you get closer to the best version of
you there's no doubt about it
if you're thinking of giving therapy a
try better help is a great option it's
convenient flexible affordable and
entirely online
and you can switch between different
therapists and I encourage you to do
this if you are seeing a therapist
and you're not really feeling a lot of
change or adjustment or it feels too
easy
that might not be good
um sometimes having a variety checking
different therapists out and seeing who
really kind of
who gets into you
can be helpful
if you want to live a more empowered
life therapy can get you there visit
betterhelp.com
t-h-e-o today to get 10 off your first
month that's better
h-e-l-p.com slash Theo
betterhelp.com Theo two title fights one
Epic night I'm talking about UFC 284
this Saturday
makachov is fighting to keep his title
and volkanovsky is hoping to make
history as the fifth champ to hold a
title in two divisions at once join the
MMA action with DraftKings sports book
official sports betting partner of UFC
new customers can bet just five dollars
and get two hundred dollars in free bets
instantly
that's right if the excitement in the
Octagon isn't enough football fans don't
forget to come join the big game action
happening next Sunday at DraftKings
sports book
download the app now and use code Theo
new customers bet just five dollars on
UFC 284 and get two hundred dollars in
free bets instantly this Saturday at
DraftKings Sportsbook with code Theo
minimum age and eligibility restrictions
apply void in Ohio see show notes for
details
you've had some like dude you've done a
really good job of like hiring like
really neat Talent like guys like Caleb
uh big cat who's your you know I don't
know if you hired him or he was a
partner no no he hired him okay yep
um you know Glenny balls uh um wow was
there Caleb
big cat and Glennie balls and put in
getting put in that category is pretty
[__] high level they're making me
some better guys I don't know and big
Freddie or whatever who's the guy that's
right the tank yeah that guy yeah listen
we've hired uh I bet the under on him
huh he's a big dude he'll surprise you
though that's like you don't think he
can fit in an airplane seat and he can't
so he'll he'll Point uh we have Jenna
Marbles do you know her yeah yeah she
came from us really yeah dude I was in
love with her dude yeah hired out of a
tanning salon oh I could see that McAfee
Pat McAfee was us really yeah we've had
we have a pretty good like roster how do
you pick Talent like do you like now
obviously people end up usually speaking
mostly of people's successes right do
you feel like you've had a good eye for
it or do you feel like you've had just
as many hits and misses what do you
think no we definitely have a good eye
for it and we have misses for sure I
think though the biggest
thing we have an eye for it and we don't
control people at all so you know we
hire somebody and there's like you do
you and and
hopefully they find the word like Caleb
use an example like we saw him uh he was
running up and down the sidelines of
North Carolina he was like because they
wouldn't because he never started yeah
and it but he wasn't even uniform his
his title was like I think the professor
of morale or director of morale so he
had his blonde hair he'd wear like a uh
ex North Carolina professional football
player who's now in the league their
number we saw him on TV like who the
[__] is this kid we had him on one of
our shows like oh he's got a weird brain
that's what we say like we look for
weird brains yeah guys and we hired him
and it's like yeah do whatever you want
and you know he kind of he was always
talented and funny bounced around kind
of trying to find his Niche and then he
the Sunday conversation which is now his
his kind of trademark thing and is great
that took a couple years for him to like
fit that exact perfect role and we just
let people sort of do that so I think
it's the combo we have a good eye for
talent but more so we we are so free in
in letting and I don't know if that's
just we're lazy or whatever but we never
tell people right what to do it's like
you're hired we'll give you the
resources do whatever you want and we've
had a lot of hits because of it like PMT
which is Big Cat yeah dude like that was
all his idea I mean totally
like I thought podcast when when I first
heard about podcaster a guy Kevin Clancy
who's been with us forever oh yeah yeah
like that's a stupid idea podcast you'll
never make money doing that but they
[__] did it obviously they were
smarter than me call her daddy that came
from us yeah yeah Alice Cooper so yeah
we've had a lot of uh
a lot a lot of big big successful people
that really were I mean McAfee played in
the NFL but no one knew him on the media
side a lot of big people that million
dollars worth of game is a huge like
Urban podcast with us right now
um so yeah we've had a lot of big
successes
um was there someone that you can you
turn the heat on a little chilly out
Yeah I broke out my scarf game for today
I want to become a scarf guy yeah really
yeah oh that's a move I feel like yeah
it is this is a first time kind of
debuting going with it but yeah it's
good I took I was taking off in the car
I'm like you know what I'm gonna try and
maybe get into the scar phase of my life
there is something nice it feels like it
unless you feel a little bit Regal or
you feel like at least they'll let you
in a department store at the time and
I'm starting to get like fat it kind of
like how do you say that on a video the
other day you were saying how like yeah
I'm sorry I put on weight it comes with
the age so it's like I I've been eat
doing the pizza thing forever uh my
shoulders all [__] so yeah I think
it's just you know life yeah
um was there a was there a higher uh or
a uh fire or something because oh I
wanted to say this yeah Caleb whenever I
got to know Caleb one thing he Raves
about is that he loves working for you
yeah he he's he's been great I think I
mean he genuinely like you know what I'm
saying like some people say my job but
he has I mean he absolutely loves it I
think it's two things for him that
probably he likes working for us me is
the freedom which I just said and I
always do what I say so
I have the back of the talent as much as
I can always but like if I say something
it's it's Bond I actually think in his
contract he has something like when Penn
bought us he's like if there's a
disagreement between Penn and me or
something like Dave gets to make the
final decision he just so he just trusts
that he is good to work for somebody
where you you know you can trust like
they have your best interest and I do
and some people may not like what I say
or do but I'm pretty straightforward and
the track words is like there like 20
years I've been pretty consistently
straightforward honest truthful yeah
is there a higher or a departure that
you regret or that you like somebody
that you let go or anything or did you
have any no I mean we we hired Mike
Rappaport this is a big [__] I don't
like that guy right now uh he doesn't
like me he doesn't like me that that was
at the Block like I I literally
if I throw a punch I've never been a
fight in my life never thrown a punch in
Anger if I threw a punch right now with
my left arm it would dislocate that's
how [__] up my shoulders are he got me
so mad I sent them a contract to fight
him like that's how [__] that ended
terribly uh the McAfee thing with us
didn't end great but like I don't really
have regrets he was always going to be
like a huge star on his own he's so good
at so many things so no not not too much
yeah I mean we're we've become to a
degree
and I always said a Saturday Night Live
model like we bring unknown Talent and
try to make them stars and we'll keep
them as long as we can keep them but
really you know if we can't hopefully
they go become big somewhere else and it
adds more credibility for us right
because then people like oh this is a
place where I can get a start and build
my name and either stay with Barstool or
not we've been pretty good at that like
we got a girl now Brianna chicken fry
she's [__] exploding like yeah she's
she's becoming big so yeah she's cute I
saw her on your thing is she is that
Native American what is chicken fry that
was just she likes chicken fries
like you know like the I think it was
Burger King right chicken fries chicken
fries yeah so oh it's not a last name no
no that was her when we hired her she
already had like Brianna chicken fries
those are Tick Tock user handle oh okay
I think she liked chicken fries late at
night what's up she likes eating late at
night yeah yeah
um oh I was wondering I thought maybe
she was like Cherokee imagine that'd be
like your Native American name chicken
fry that'd be [__] fire yeah
yeah I almost knocked up this Native
American Girl one time so I met this
girl in a motel right
so how does that work like is there like
uh does do motels have like
Motel bars or like you just saw walking
in a room oh no no this girl we met on
uh social media right got it and this
was probably Instagram I might even
remember no it was an intentional Meetup
yeah so she drove I think like 10 or 11
hours too and she drove from like she's
a red flag oh yeah yeah it was and she
was a Native American
and so she drove in
and she and uh we ended up making love
or whatever I don't remember exactly
what happened but then on the drive home
I guess she got kind of bored and she
starts saying well if I'm pregnant I'm
gonna keep this child and now I'm like
right out right yeah although to her
defense you probably do have a lot of
time to think
on a 10-hour drive that's a good point
that takes a lot of things go through
your mind yeah I should have given her
at least five hours to be hypothetically
pregnant on that yeah yeah like a
10-hour Drive you're you're you're
thinking a lot of [__] yeah yeah
especially when you're just driving back
to the res or whatever and she just get
back there there's a bunch of free
gasoline from the government and you're
like what the [__] am I gonna do with
this family you know if I have a family
but anyway she got intense and God that
made me so nervous uh
did you um because you got into a
relationship you are I was married I'm
in a relationship now okay in a
relationship now and was it did you were
you looking for a relationship or did
this kind of happen which one the my
current girlfriend current girlfriend no
no
um so like
my ex-wife basically I met when I
started Barcelo right about the same
time and I'm still like best friends
with her she's the best uh and then I
was single for a while probably uh
being living a a crazier lifestyle let's
say like it was a totally different time
because
parcel with nothing and they're to it
obviously like being well known fame
money brings more women and
opportunities in your life so I've seen
you [__] on Twitter a little at some
point I had seen something you know oh
yeah no I didn't watch all of it yeah
there's some stuff out there that you
know
good for you man you know I get
embarrassed like if I'm I even walk out
of the room backwards because I don't
want women seeing my butt and stuff no I
was a big video guy like I I that that
probably and back in time it's like who
the [__] would ever want to watch me
[__] so yeah uh but so I don't know five
years single and then just met her uh
Sylvanas her name it was pretty organic
yeah and do you is it kind of less
stressful because I start to find that
like
like as you start you you don't want to
just like hook up with strangers it gets
a little bit like scary kind of like you
know it's like I don't want a child like
a even a possible child somewhere yeah I
no I was pretty free and loose uh
I would never like in hindsight
I was probably a [__] idiot because
there's a lot of a lot of post [__] that
I've dealt with that a lot of people
know about me I mean I I you know hit
pieces written about me about my sexual
activity sex tapes about it all which I
never would have guessed for like
[__] me like that if if someone back
in high school was like wait till you
[__] see what this guy is gonna turn
out to be like I I would have never
[__] guessed it uh so yeah I was
probably playing uh fast and loose is
how I describe it but whatever it's um
it's been a wild ride I'll say that yeah
it's been exciting man I think it seems
like it's really been exciting do you
feel like a pressure like I feel the
pressure as I get older to try and stay
like younger and stuff does that feel
hard for you does it no no I I feel like
it's been a fairly natural thing like I
so I probably cram so much into that
five years of being single like go I
never went to clubs really ever and then
I started going out a lot and you know I
went from the guy who's like with his
buddies if you're trying to save up to
go at once like how the [__] am I going
to afford this table only [__] losers
would pay for that table all our girls
are there but it's like I can't [__]
afford this to you know you're getting
opportunity like I remember I was just
saying on the way over like Super Bowl
is coming up and I'm getting every
invite in the book like hey come to this
party you have a table here a table
there and I sent it to this guy Paul Gaz
who's who's been employed basically
number one worked at my kitchen table we
went to a Super Bowl party and we had to
pay 25 grand for a table for us that's
like do we have it credit card can we do
it and they [__] put us in a
satellite room we weren't even in the
room where the [__] party was
happening we were watching the party on
a TV and I just I sent them the link I'm
like man times have changed we're
getting but so I I did that phase I mean
I was doing drugs I was going out all
the time yeah it was just like a very
different phase in my life now I really
don't like being in clubs at all like I
sylvana my girlfriend still loves it but
I've I've toned it I've gotten heard me
like listen I can't I I don't want to be
there like it's not where I want to be I
don't feel comfortable I actually do
feel old in those situations yeah the
first time in my life I look around like
damn I'm a [__] old guy in here so
that part of my life I think is pretty
much in the rear view like Super Bowl
yeah I'll go out but I mean I was going
out
[__]
four or five days a week damn pretty
pretty heavy pretty heavy and will you
party in priyo could you party pretty
hard or not yeah I was I never I never
used to but yeah and I was we're y'all
doing drugs too cocaine I'm not a big
Coke guy people always think I'm a Coke
guy I'm pretty honest about uh I think
it's the hair probably
this looks like a hair oh the hair looks
like I'll find a gram in it son yeah
I think it looks like uh like a what
maybe now especially since you live in
Florida maybe that adds to it like you
think like oh this guy yeah no I was I
was doing a lot Adderall would be like I
do a lot just to even wake up work
um I guess he's the best drug there is
like yeah you know I never get like
depressed on it
um but no I was never big on Coke but
like for me to be out I don't know how
people I mean what are you Miami doesn't
[__] close oh yeah Miami's insane man
so you're there even the trees man
you'll walk by two trees will be [__]
enough away it literally like is like
you walk out of 11 and there's a [__]
line at 9am yeah it's just I don't even
know what people do then yeah how you
work and what are you doing and people
don't start going out it's like hey you
want to go at 11 it's like sure you're
gonna be the only [__] in the club
like nobody's out yet so it's a super
late City uh and
yeah I was I was definitely partying I
was definitely partying dude a friend of
mine got all coked up one night fell off
of his balcony right landed on another
balcony right and T.I the rapper came
out and found him
yeah he's a big T.I is a big big Miami
guy yeah yeah there's all sorts of [__]
I remember I was like who who was it uh
who's who's the Miami guys I was at 11
there's another rapper who was always in
Miami whatever whoever this guy he's a
big rapper I and
the camera guy came up I moved out of
the way he's like hey this guy ruins the
story not knowing him I'll probably
think of it put Miami rapper look at
Google Miami rapper is wizzy thick guy
no he's a little guy okay oh it might be
uh what's his name uh
who has that same beat over and over
again
um
uh uh but he's from Atlanta that guy uh
he wears the the the green gloves in
that one video
ludicrous no no no Pitbull Sean Kingston
no no he's a little skinny guy
oh oh uh he's been around forever but
he's like still super popular Nelly
isn't going to bother the [__] out of me
not Nelly
play Guess That rapper
T I almost it was similar I feel like
Bobby Shmurda no no I feel like it was
keep going down
Hulk Hogan no not a rapper uh Jason
Derulo I did pizza review with him
though
he seems like a nice guy he was he ate
pizza with no no cheese though which is
wild you know who told me the Earth was
flat two black guys at a pizza parlor
the Earth was flat first time I ever
heard it
that's Kyrie uh yeah it might have been
who the [__] am I thinking of I
can't Dahlia who lives in Miami he
actually just he
I want to say it was with a t too but I
can't remember Trick Daddy no I like
that song though take it to the house uh
my who
whatever the story is [__] ruined
yeah
it's ruined forget the [__] dude I
did uh I went to Paris fashion week last
week right and which was crazy yeah
which is crazy right so this guy
um comb delaying he's like a fashion guy
right he makes fashion so he had um
comedians come and be in his fashion
show Andrew Schultz went
um a couple of other guys
uh and
it's the fashion finally was at like 11
p.m and Kodak Black is sitting in there
with a baby in the front row
like he he
you all time
name drops I was credited
in Kodak Black and pardoned by Trump
were you really yes
he credited you Trump mentioned
some convoluted like Kodak Black
actually reached out to me like during
the uh Barstool fund I think he donated
and then trumped when he pardon him he's
like Kodak Black donated to like Dave
Portner the Barcelo funny is like a good
guy it was a little blurb I was like
what the [__] world am I in like Kodak
Black Trump crazy yeah everything's
crazy now it is does it excite you or
does it scare you like how everything
the lines are so blurred Everything
feels so crazy the news you can't trust
the news anymore so there's conspiracy
theories people are always like there's
all these conspiracy theories but it's
like a lot of it is because you can't
rely on the news so people are gonna try
and get whatever they think the news is
yeah no I the whole thing yeah that
which I agree I don't trust the [__]
news like everybody has an angle yeah
I've said that boy I don't even know
where you go if you want like a a
non-spin take on something where the
[__] do you go I don't know
um so yeah that that is just a way of
life uh but I don't know I found it
crazy everyone's just got an agenda yeah
everybody every there's nobody who
doesn't have an agenda I know it's
getting weird huh yeah yeah big time I
just wonder kind of how does that end
you know or do we evolve out of it you
know like everything's gotten so like me
you know
um
I don't know it's an interesting it
definitely feels like an interesting
time to be alive um you got to go and do
Joe Rogan Experience that was your first
time right yeah it was my first time
what were you pretty nervous tell me
about that yeah I I didn't know what to
expect I I really didn't because I was a
huge podcast guy and I people always I
always got like hey you should go on
Rogan
um
yeah I'm not like ever somebody really
necessarily I did ask to go on Rogan
once and that was when all the [__]
negative [__] was happening I wanted to
say my case but I didn't know what to
expect uh his Studio was sick it was
easy like and and I met the producer
Jamie before he's like I know all the
bar stool [__] I have no idea what he's
gonna talk about he may talk about all
of it none of it
um smoked a cigar I'm not a cigar I got
like [__] weirdly high from smoking
it's hard isn't it yeah it's like I am
not a cigar guy in his studio is like
trippy right it's like with the little
the lights and it went by quick my main
thing honestly because I know he goes so
long it's like if I go two hours that
probably means he [__] didn't like me
and like I'm out so once it ended I'm
like how long was it but it was cool and
it's so big you know you don't even real
I mean I know how big he is because
we're sore in the business but even
still like after we did it so many
people just walking down the streets
like oh listen to Rogan show the phone I
mean his reaches is crazy he's probably
the most influential you know guy in
media there is I think think so I think
it's been like that for a while yeah you
know I think and especially people
didn't realize that until he got that
big contract that almost kind of I mean
it was amazing for him and and he
deserves it but when they put out that
article that he made like a hundred
million a year or something yeah and I
think it was twice that but uh that's
when everybody like that's when people
started attacking and that's when you
saw these hit pieces it's like
it's just it's so dangerous kind of like
um
I don't know the the the the media is
just so scary it's like they can shape
anything any way they want and I
uh he he he's definitely perceived as a
threat because he he's he uses escape
velocity whatever but you can't control
right if you can't control how somebody
thinks and you really can't hurt them
that that is a threat I think the
attacks come when and why they came
because what's the point really of going
after him when he's a solo guy you don't
give a [__] when you have Spotify
there's a thought I can get to him now
right because spot is now Spotify the
pen yeah it's like Spotify backed him up
but I mean he did have to delete it uh
episodes and maybe say things that
ordinary life was by himself maybe would
have maybe he wouldn't have but I think
that is that's the switch it's like aha
he kind of has the answer to somebody
now whether he actually does or he
doesn't but somebody's signing his
checks right before nobody is so what's
the point of going out what is that
going to do because you may just
actually ignite more because he doesn't
give a [__] his audience is his audience
yeah that would be to me the GIF
difference and why it happened when he
did that yeah
um yeah I remember when I first went in
dude I was Sinners I got a twit a tweet
a DM from him in the middle like in just
like 11 p.m or something but I was going
to bed early so it's like middle of the
night but
um
and it was like hey do you want to call
my show and I remember being like Oh my
God I was excited too when I got it yeah
because if you people always hit me up
like hey can you have me get on or sit
and it's like there's no real way to get
like Joe like will literally hit people
up that's exactly that's how he does it
it was mine so the New York Times wrote
basically a hit piece on me and it
they're working on for a year I knew
about it they dug through my entire
[__] past like so trash
every single person that I was friends
with in my network they're reaching I
was having girls call me like I didn't
even know or send me DMS being like what
is this about
um a year long they really found nothing
it turned into just like again like I'm
a scumbag gambling hippies the point of
the story the reporter wrote in the
article like we reached out to Dave for
comment he didn't reach back and I
posted my exchanges with this woman and
they went back I think seven months
where I'm like hey I know you're digging
into my past I will sit down meet with
you we both get to record you can ask me
anything I'll answer anything you want
I'm right here she kept responding I'm
eager to meet soon soon this went on for
months of her being like I'm eager to
meet with you I'll talk to you soon
ghost for like uh five six articles she
writes the whole article she's like you
have 48 hours to respond to a million
bullet points I'm like [__] that it's
like I gave you the opportunity and I
posted the exchange Rogan saw that and
he's like the New York Times it's the
worst and that that prompted it and
actually I have my phone so I I she she
never is the reporter never responded I
wrote her name is Emily Steele this lady
wrote the article on me this is Friday
January 13th I just tweeted a thank you
for the hit piece you wrote on me it's
what landed me on Rogan and introduced a
brand new audience to me thank you for
being a hater it actually made my brand
stronger than ever thank you so I just
sent her that little [__] for you yeah
they [__] do that [__] man they do
that [__] they sneak around people call
somebody call your old employer it's
crazy and it's like I've always said hey
I'm here like I'm I'm saying I'll sit
down you can ask me [__] anything and
record it as long as I can too if you're
trying to do a fair and what's crazy
like I grew up you know in my brain like
the New York Times is like legit yeah
that is what I thought of the New York
Times so I always look at that unless
you're in this [__] world and you're
like part of it like even my dad who's a
liberal hates [__] Trump that type of
guy like he still has a hard time being
like Yeah The New York Times is biased
like he almost has to because he's seen
it but it it it is scary because if
you're not in it you just believe like
most normal people aren't gonna do the
back research no no hit piece they're
like oh that's true so that that part of
it is [__] scary well it's even like
even headlines in anything yeah if
somebody writes like Larry's gay and you
see that as the headline like damn dude
right because he's gay yeah you hear
Larry's gay yeah Larry's [__] gay ad
they didn't even know who they didn't
even look at if who it is if it's
Lawrence or who it is yeah no that is
nobody it's just like and then it's like
and there's never any apology that's the
weirdest thing you're like you're you're
there's never any like recuperate or any
uh so Business Insider who I [__]
hate wrote uh hit piece on me and it was
vicious basically made me sound like a
rapist and like within 24 hours I had
all the receipts like oh thank God
um of like well here's all the proof
that this is totally [__] [__] I
was I guess naive at the time like oh
they're gonna retract it say apology
they said they wrote another article and
my lawyer was like well they can now say
It's News it's like well it's only news
because they [__] wrote it but it
becomes new it's like what what kind of
[__] up game is this it's news now
it's crazy it's [__] crazy I went all
the way [__] sue their asses and it
it just the judge came back they're like
there's no way
being bad at your job isn't an excuse to
like so it's almost like Johnny Depp
Johnny Depp when he's sued he originally
sued the newspaper and lost because the
newspaper can always be like well we
didn't know that she wasn't telling the
truth or we didn't look at any of the
other evidence you have to sue the
actual like he sued Amber Heard so the
whole thing's [__] I know huh makes me
really jaded yeah dude this [__] makes
everybody mad I think as you start to
feel like there's no way to win against
this thing and whatever this thing is
but it starts to feel like there's
something that you can't you know the
only way I look at it
people [__] hate me are always going
to hate me I could cure cancer they'd be
like why didn't you do it faster now the
flip side the people like me and love me
are always going to love me and and I've
said before what's great now I tell the
truth but my crowd is so kind of like
in my corner it and I wasn't but if I
wasn't telling the truth they'd probably
still believe me it's like it's almost
they're on my side and the people aren't
aren't now I good for the people like me
I do tell the truth and it's always
honest but it's so hard to convince once
people have their minds set up or made
up it's hard to get them off that point
they they just ignore like facts yeah
yeah people want to be blind and facts
that's kind of bizarre but then
sometimes I wonder how much do I fall
into the same trap even myself you know
it's like I sometimes wonder that
um
we saw this thing like BuzzFeed was
starting to use like AI to generate
articles do you see that yeah stock went
up like a bazillion percent because of
it but do you like because you have like
real you know employees with alcoholism
and whatever else yeah we got the real
deal yeah you guys got the [__] guy
you know he's right there you know some
guys you know gonna overdose or his
wife's gonna leave him because he's
writing another article for you you know
it's like you got yeah but you got real
people we got real people yeah you got
real people with [__] asthma you know
like [__] real [__]
um does this kind of [__] scare you or
do you think this is cheap or do you
think anything about it it's a business
I mean
I I feel like BuzzFeed has always been
the lowest common denominator for talent
so it doesn't surprise me nothing will
ever for our business we look for weird
talented people there's no AI or
anything like that who can you know
reply well any balls uh but no this is
in our world
it doesn't scare me it doesn't surprise
me
um because it says buzzfeed's using AI
to write its articles after firing 180
employees yeah and they're talking about
their like listicles and [__] right so
they're just aggregating I feel bad for
the people who got fired too but I
wouldn't say those people were like the
Pinnacle of like Talent you know right
um so yeah you know thoreau's no walls
yeah you're coming up with like the you
know that I don't know 10 things you
should [__] be doing when you like
come home after your groceries I don't
know what the [__] yeah yeah 10 things
you do when your cat dies yeah right
yeah so they're just aggregating it
again I do feel bad for the employees uh
but this isn't I won't view BuzzFeed as
like my world necessarily we really are
looking for like talented people yeah or
weirdos
yeah me and Caleb wanted to try and do a
show you know
it would be fun I like spending time
with him
uh the the bigger I I would say the
bigger
threat if you want to call it to my
world our world is the evolution of like
technology let's take you for example
there's probably a world back when we
started where you wouldn't have nearly
the vehicles to get your name out there
without like coming to us you know or or
somebody or tick tocker like Tick Tock
doesn't exist so if you're a talented
person how do you get your content out
there it's far fewer places
um so that that's the harder thing
because you know we really have to find
the talent early early because once
someone's pre-established on social
media or through their platforms they
don't need us at all so that that's the
harder thing with do you have somebody
looking for that kind of thing yeah
we're always looking for talent really
always now when you say always looking
but you have like it's like an employee
that's actively kind of no we don't
right so I guess not we're we're always
willing to hire Talent if we find it
right right but it it is hard you got to
get them super early and and our value
prop on that early is basically we'll be
like gasoline will accelerate you you
sign you know a generally like a two
three year contract and if you're good
good
being in our Network should really like
give you maybe a a way to cut the line
so to speak to get your name out there
then you can reevaluate you want to stay
with us you want to do it on your own
that type of thing yeah
um what do you think anything about like
this GP this GP Chat thing that thing
that can make all its own articles and
stuff it can write papers you know is
that what's the difference between that
and the listicle [__] chat gbt can be
like hey will you write me a um
a paper
you know it's a Dave Portnoy writes a
paper on uh young men trying to meet
each other in the 17th century right
yeah at night yep and you put that
information in there and then it'll do
like a three-page paper that would be in
your voice sounds like a good [__]
way to like get through school yeah
I just wonder how weird that's going to
get if every you know like I at the same
questions I mean the same questions I
guess would come it's like well they're
sourcing the information from somewhere
you know so who's fact like
how do you know where you're getting the
information from what's real what's not
what's biased that doesn't change that
part of it yeah I don't know yeah I
guess in the end in the end I think
you're still gonna have to have real
talent will prevail
I think even with stuff like this
hopefully most people are going to see
through like oh this is just another
[__] article yeah and it's not
anything that even a human wrote I feel
like you can see that stuff pretty
easily on the internet and if you're
falling for that [__] then you you are
something is wrong with you and
yeah I don't know what what these things
will be used for exactly but I I know in
our world at least
a lot of what people like is because
they are attached to the personalities
so like if if you switch the names on
who like you I it changes how people
perceive it because
if it's Theo Vaughn wrote or did
something people know you and they view
it through that lens and that affects
their enjoyment or lack thereof yeah you
know yeah like when Frank left the Jags
game early that [__] broke my I was like
what is even going on but I found myself
enveloped in his life I want to know
what's going on why is he leaving her I
didn't know I was leaving early either
at blew my it's like this is the best
game and he flew all the way you're
talking to bills bills Dolphins yeah
Bill's Dolphins sorry when he left and
when Frank left the Bills Dolphins game
early I just that's the attitude of
Barstool and and full display he I think
I was mad at first because like why'd we
[__] send him there yeah if he can't
stay and by the way you're never gonna
make a six six pm flight the game is
long but the game's at one you're gonna
be sitting in traffic there's no chance
so it was doomed from the beginning so
like this went through like 10 different
things at parcel like people booked it
it's like in what world you can't it's a
one o'clock game you're never gonna make
six so yeah yeah he's in that Park a lot
with
and I think he really thought he had to
leave he's like what do you talk like of
course you'll stay stay the night and
fly it's crazy
um Tom Brady just retired yeah yeah did
you feel anything about that so he's
he's do you know Tom
very Loosely all right but I have like a
long history with him because of where I
grew up like of course you know I uh
the good the bad the ugly like so he
first of all he wants the same school as
me Michigan so he's the same year okay
so oh really he remembers from college
yeah yeah so went to college with him
then he comes to the Pats and I'm I'm in
Boston and in the Patriots rise uh
really coincided with the bar stool rise
so we're so closely linked together
everything since I've been involved with
like the cops twice with Brady once in a
negative fashion once in well cops
involved is never good but one
anti-brady I guess you could say and one
pro like so he way back in the day uh
he he basically Giselle was on the beach
with their little kid Ben he was an
infant Ben Brady god wow uh and he was
naked who was Thomas no Ben the kid with
Gisele on a beach myself Beach Miami
naked too if I was with her yeah well
keep in mind the kid's an infant her son
oh okay so it's his son tiny little like
the Gerber baby oh wow huge dick huge
dick no way for a little baby and you
saw it how far away were you no it was a
[__] Paparazzi photo it was on the
internet and I could see that wand on
him yeah and I made a joke that going
deep this was the height of the Peyton
Manning Tom Brady like rivalry so I I
wrote a Blog in this one blog he said
check out the Howitzer on Brady's baby
and I wrote a sentence below I go Peyton
Manning could never have a kid with this
big of a hog or something like this
world war three broke out Dave's a
pedophile he's sexualizing kids the kid
was an infant police knocked on my door
and Austin came in like we're gonna make
your life real [__] horrible if you
don't take this down like people are
saying I should be beaten to death it
was oh it's like Mystic River it was
crazy so
that was way early and then fast forward
the Patriots explode where we end up
going to jail defending Brady for when
he got suspended by the NFL handcuffed
ourselves to each other at NFL
Headquarters I've been dragged out of
the Super Bowl in handcuffs
um Bob Kraft the owner of the team when
Brady came back with Tampa Bay called me
up he's like I want you to be my guest
for when Brady comes back so it's been
the full circle and I have met him I
think a couple times
um but I like so if I saw him I'd be
like hey Tommy like hey Dave how's it
going good to see you but I don't know
him like on a real personal level but
yeah it's uh
their success and everything that
happened with the Patriots
I don't think Barstool probably is the
same if that doesn't happen it put us in
the headlines in a lot of different ways
so it's just a weird magical ride it
really has been it's been nuts
real fascinating man congratulations
just on getting to have that experience
because life you know to have the ups
and downs to have all of it you know to
really have so many experiences
football's so big in this country and
the Super Bowl's so big and we became
Barstool the face of like the Patriot
fan like there's a game they could
probably pull if you pull up like uh
Goodell clown towel so could tell a
commissioner in a league like the first
time he came back to uh Gillette after
all the controversy we printed like 70
000 of these towels with his face and a
nose and we we got we're like we need
volunteers to hand these things out
it was a big [__] thing like if you
you can if you on the images for it oh
yeah you'll see like the whole [__]
Stadium basically
oh
like go to the bottom right we had the
shirts so yeah like wow there you are
yeah so like the whole [__] Stadium
you Dell in there it just it was a wild
time and and we became people just they
hated us because people hated the
Patriots like but that was your thing
you did was it bar stools in here it's
like this infection it's like this yeah
it's almost like this like this plague
but it's not a negative plague it's like
this
disrupter yeah and the Patriots were the
most talked about hated loved whatever
team for like two decades oh yeah and
we're just right in the middle of it I
remember Tony Collins by there didn't he
was that Tony yeah you're going way back
yeah yeah running back yeah I I I got to
meet him one time he went to ECU he's a
cool cat man yeah I like Tony Collins
but I think he played in their Super
Bowl game that would have been 85 and
they lost to the Bears man yeah yeah wow
yeah yeah yeah yup that was when the
Patriots they were very good that Steve
Grogan was like my guy he was like I
loved him yeah that I mean the Patriots
are for the most part terrible franchise
up to Bill the Brady hour they had two
Super Bowls um and the second one being
the Parcells but like if you like Tech
Mobile did you ever play like oh yeah
like they're the worst team in Tech
Mobile very sad I can't even remember
they had a lot of I think one of the
running back was white I think even
could have uh yeah Craig James
half the Pony Express yeah I mean yeah
them in the Colts are the two worst
teams in it
yeah that was a lot
um what do you got for the Super Bowl
man where are you landing at with it
I don't know I'm back and forth uh I
think right now you gotta see if the
Chiefs get healthy their wide receivers
are so banged up but if they get back I
I think they get a pretty good shot I
bet it'll be a good game I think we're
heading out there so we have a bar in
Scottsdale which is cool so oh nice yeah
we'll be doing like live radio there all
week so we'll be there the whole time oh
wow oh yeah I'm trying to see if I'm
gonna get over there I I expect to see
you yeah I think we'll probably figure
hopefully I'll figure something out
um yeah I feel like the eagles it just
feels like there's some kind of weird
Destiny thing going on there I mean
they're just tearing people up I can't
tell I mean it's the game they beat San
Fran no quarterback like anybody could
be I mean I've never seen an NFL team
they literally couldn't throw a forward
pass so you're not gonna win many games
that way I think the Giants suck
the Eagles will number one team best
team the whole time in the NFC but I
don't know how good they are right yeah
that division there was no there was so
much disparity in the League this year
between like good teams there's like
there's so many bands and I thought the
AFC was overall better but I think the
Eagles are very good yeah they're gonna
be a very good game yeah yeah I think
it's going to be exciting
um what did you have you seen this power
slap and stuff yes
it's crazy
what do you mean by crazy because it's
because people are getting like well
their faces are getting like deformed
and [__] yeah one guy's wife couldn't
recognize him you know so that's crazy
yeah I saw the clip of the woman doing
like the somersault after yeah no I see
it's nuts it's nuts well I mean people
love that [__] it does remind me of
early UFC like Earl UFC because if you
go Google it
a lot of hate out there online like this
is the worst thing that's ever [__]
happened
um you know obvious a lot of people have
opinions on Dana White
his incident oh that was crazy that that
happened right when the league started I
almost feel like I wonder if that was
planned it's like unbelievable
um because his wife's at least a lot or
she's probably bantamweight I don't know
I didn't get it's hard to see I don't
know about that uh I don't know what
what qualification would be but
so if you Google it there's law hate
right but
it's entertaining
but people are getting hurt one guy
bought a van right if you see that the
guy left the place and bought a van for
no reason like and he didn't even
there was no re like something so
they're saying his brain got you know
like his wires got crossed and
something's like you got to buy a van
yeah imagine this going first of all
imagine buying a van yeah that's kind of
cool yeah kind of but if you don't even
need a van you're just like hey I'm
getting a vet like you [__] come home
from losing the fight with them to pick
a van yeah listen it's entertaining I I
like I really do think it's early I used
to watch like the early early ufcs no
weight class that was like ancient Rome
yeah and you had to fight like you fight
you win you fight again it's like
tournament and people are like horrified
though what the [__] is this it reminds
me a lot because there's definitely
something about it and I don't know what
that says about the human psyche it's
like yeah I want to watch I like this is
[__] interesting like slap them
harder so uh it's an interesting thing I
think Dana's pretty confident it's gonna
be successful and numbers are big so
we'll see yeah it's hard to deny those
clips when you see them it's like you
want to stay on it but you don't want to
it's like that and the people like
attacking CVS workers those are the two
clips where I'm like do I want to keep
watching like [__] like that like you
just now
I'm sure they'll have to just like UFC
that's what I say it if it continues and
grows they'll have to put some
regulations which he already said but
there's something there there's
undeniable something there a human
psyche it's like yeah I want to watch
somebody get slapped so silly they do a
somersault or if it's I don't know what
it says about humans but like you said
people [__] used to go to the
Coliseum in Rome to watch [__]
Gladiator so yeah there's something
inherent to it yeah
um with all the success with Barstool
you guys have crushed it so much and and
and your journey through it do you think
that there'd be a do you ever start to
have ideas of like there's something
else you want to do down the line I know
you guys are you have a watch company
now yeah brick watch Brick watch right
that's how you tag us applied for it you
did crucified so the the number one
thing I've been crucified it for in my
life for doing watches because I they're
they're not cheap they're 2400 bucks
okay and people's nice looking thank you
it is I saw Eric Olson have one no is it
Greg Olsen yeah he had it on
um but there's a community to watch
people who take their watches so [__]
seriously that I did I was I built mine
was like built for people like me who
I'm not gonna spend like 10 grand on
Rolex but I thought I want a watch
that's clean looks good I spent a lot of
time like coming up with the design of
it it's more of a fashion watch people
went under the hood they it was
we'll see what happens with it but
whenever I post it like watch snobs they
come from my throat really crazy like
time knots he's like [__] yeah yeah
yes time knots it's like a [__]
second monkeys out yeah no they're
they're like I could buy this watch for
this [__] has this movement and does
this and [__] sucks my dick and you
know it doesn't do that they're crazy
watch people
and they thought they're like you're
doing it as a scam it's like what the
[__] you talking about doing out of this
game why like no I'm not and it's like
by the way I'm at the point and maybe
rightly or wrongly where I can get
investors for every people like oh he's
a smart business guy so if I'm like I'm
doing something people knew I was doing
this they were like begging to throw
money and I was like no because honestly
if it doesn't work I don't want you to
be able to be like in my grill like if
I'll lose my own money and I don't have
to worry about a phone call from anybody
yeah that's kind of nice huh yeah so I
it's my own money that I I either will
lose or make but yeah it's been a wild
experience I've done a the
people it's slowed down a little bit but
when I launch it people coming for the
throat but to answer a question beyond
that and that was just something I I
thought would work right it's like I I
it's kind of that entrepreneurial spirit
I spent a year or so year and a half
developing it beyond that
one misconception I think people have
always had about me is like I'm ultra
driven like to do [__] like I think I
have two more years with barcel
guaranteed
um
and that could disappear to a beach who
[__] knows like I don't I don't know
I I don't have that inherent need I
don't think to work hmm people don't
believe me about that they think I'm an
egomaniac like I'll have to be in the
headlines I don't we'll see
I mean always an instigator I just don't
know if that'll kind of disappear and I
hope it doesn't you know it's fun to
watch you instigate through the world I
think yeah you know it's been really
entertaining I mean it's been
entertaining
um you know I've long been a fan and
then I got to meet you and you seem like
a very uh you just seemed a lot more
even down to earth than I expected man
and I know that's a weird it's not a
compliment to give someone but I think
you look at someone's life and it looks
so busy and insane and then you meet
them and they seem uh you know it's
interesting to find that somebody that
seems kind of down to earth
um so like I'm sure with like in your
work like there's a lot of decisions to
be made right have you always been a
good decision maker do you have like a
process when it comes to that because
you probably have to make decisions
pretty quick yeah no I just go with my
gut like uh I always view it
sort of Family Feud style like you know
if you watch a Family Feud you got the
head guy at the table right oh yeah and
then everyone shouts the answers at them
if you hear a good answer you're like
all right I'll go with that guy but even
if they have the right answer but in my
gut I'm like no I get the right answer
I'll go with mine I may get the X but it
that's kind of how it is it's all gut
based yeah yeah there's no
it
I look at this I follow my gut since I
started we've been wildly successful a
lot a lot of breaks that I could have
never dreamed of and I didn't start
barcel really to like be here I just
didn't want to hate my job waking up in
the morning but uh why would I stop
following my gut it's got us this far so
you have a mentor that you reach out to
if there's things that like you're
unsure about occasionally there's a
couple guys uh there's there's dude Mike
rapoli
um who I met through horse racing he
started like
um Vitamin Water he started
um body armor so he sold both for like
billions he's a crazy guy but down to
earth nice so sometimes like business
questions I'll ask him Erica nardini our
CEO we have like the best relationship
so I'll run [__] by her
um
you know my family but
those are those are kind of it we met a
guy who sells they do like horse you
know the horse uh
does sex with other horses oh yeah yeah
breeding and their horse was like a
champion it won like a
it won the damn
you know
I don't know what it is the Kentucky
Derby no I think it was like brick stone
or Bricktown or I don't know what it's
called but uh yeah maybe Kentucky Derby
I can't remember but that or the
Brookstone or the Brickstone so they're
wondering so but people will pay and he
said like like all through the week
there's just lines of like people
bringing in their horse and the horse
has sex with it and then
they'd make like thirty thousand dollars
every time the horse pumps and it's just
out there pumping all all fall yeah
that's crazy yeah what that has to do
with oh rapoli I mentioned the horse guy
yeah breeding that's where all the money
is God yeah and they have to have it
like natural you can't like artificial
inseminate it has to they actually have
to [__] that's part of the rules yeah
yeah cause you get to be right there he
said yeah and it's like if it doesn't
take or it doesn't work you still
[__] spend the money yeah damn boy
that's a lot for a glass yeah put it out
to stud that's basically what that's
called the male they put out stuff they
bring the females
boom bang bang
you're a busy guy and so like obviously
you're like super busy do you have like
a day-to-day routine a ritual that you
do every morning this might be a bad
question I don't know if I've been asked
yeah no it it
I've definitely taken the foot off the
gas a little bit like the early days I I
much more do uh no not not as much
anymore I mean I have my schedule like
the BFF podcast which is like a Tuesday
we'll have college depending on sport
like sport shows to do my pizza review
is every single day so I got to make
sure those are in
um I'm gonna start day trading again
probably in March that'll be like at the
beginning of the stock market at the end
of it but I've definitely taken the gas
the foot off the pedal a little bit I
mean 20 years a long [__] time to be
doing something yeah would you ever come
up with like a investing arm through
Barstool do you think yeah I I
theoretically because uh at some point a
lot some of your fans will start to get
older yeah and they'll have in money
they want to invest yeah so well and
other things yeah yeah potentially I
don't know maybe I mean it might be
interesting you know yeah especially if
you were doing it or you get involved
with people that do it well yeah I'm
sure a lot of your supporters would want
to have the same or do the same
um are we done yeah I think we covered a
lot of stuff ma'am all right dude thanks
so much for hanging out dude yeah no
it's uh it was fun I'm glad I got to do
it yeah I appreciate it man yeah for
sure um I want to come back on BFF
sometime open invite praise brother all
right all right thanks Dave cool nah I'm
just floating on the breeze
I must be
Cornerstone
I'll share this piece of my life
[Music]